من القاهره الدكتور مادس جلبرت مسؤول
الفريق الطبي النرويجي الى قطاع غزه دكتور
جلبرت
اذا شهر يمر الان الوضع يزداد سوءا فيما
يتعلق
بالمستشفيات الاحتياجات الصحيه والطبيه
ايضا تتفاقم الوقود لم يصل وبالتالي ايضا
مزيد من المستشفيات سوف تصبح في الساعات
القادمه خارج الخدمه وبالتالي كيف تصفون
الوضع
يمكنني ان اقول لكم هذا الامر لقد سئمت
وتعبت من عد الارقام من موتى من قتل وجرحه
وان نقول للعالم ما هي حاله المستشفيات
جميعنا يعرف الحال اود ان اعرض عليكم هذا
الرجل هذا
طالب في الطاع الصحي الطبي
وقتل يوم امس مع امه ووالده و شقيقتيه و
فرد من العائله ثمانيه اشخاص قتلوا وهم
ينامون في قطاع غزه هؤلاء من المدنيين غير
المسلحين هو كان يتدرب وطبيب ويود ان
يعالج الاطفال وهو من اقرب الاصدقاء لي
اعتقد انه يتعين علينا ان نغير المنظور
ويتعين علينا ان نطرح الاسئله الاهم من هم
المسؤولون الجيش
الاسرائيلي السيد نتنياهو الرئيس جو بايدن
السيد بلينكن
هم جبناء هم جبناء هم
يهاجمون المدنيين ويقتلون المدنيين وهم
نيام ويقتلون الاطفال ويقصف المستشفيات
ويجوعون الناس وكل ذلك يحصل وكان بالامكان
ان يتوقف لو تم التوصل الى حل عادل للشعب
الفلسطيني ما من احد بحاجه الى معلومات
اضافيه الان نحن نعرف ان النظام الصحي
الفلسطيني تعرض لضغط كبير ونهار وذلك بسبب
الجيش الاسرائيلي بدعم من الكونجرس
الامريكي نحن نعرف ان مستشفيات ينقصها
المعدات والادويه والماء والطعام والوقود
نحن نعرف ان الاطفال يحرقون في قطاع غزه
وفي حقيقه الامر ليس لديهم الادويه وعندما
يقومون بتضميد الجراح يجدون شضايا
من المتفجرات في جسد الاطفال نحن نعرف ان
الناس يموتون في الا في المستشفيات وكان
بالامكان انقاذ ارواح هؤلاء لو كان لدى
المستشفيات المعدات والوقود كل ذلك معلوم
لمده اربعه اسابيع الان نحن نعرف ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قتل قتل 4000 طفل فلسطيني هل
نحن بحاجه الى الحديث بشكل متزايد عن
الارقام والمستشفيات اليوم قصفوا ثلاثه
مستشفيات
جديده
المستشفى اللي رط
والمستشفى الوحيد للامراض النفسيه في قطاع
غزه اقول هذا كما قال صديقي طبيب اليوم
العالم يتدهور
والانسانيه لم تعد موجوده الانسانيه
الوحيده يعبر عنها الملايين من الناس
الذين خرجوا الى الطرقات في واشنطن في
لندن في دبي في اوسلو في كل مكان في
العالم لكي يقولوا كف وقفوا عن
القتل من خلال خبرتك ما الذي يفسر هذا
التعاطي الدولي مع ما يجري في غزه الصوره
تصل الوضع يصل الناس العالم كله يعلم ما
يجري وفتاحه ما يجري في غزه تجاوزنا الشهر
وما زال الوضع على حاله بل ازداد سوءا
وبالتالي هل من تفسير لهذه
السلبيه
في الحقيقه انت وانا وجميع المشاهدين نعرف
جميعا ان هناك قوى سياسيه تود ذلك هذه هي
الخطه خطه القضاء على الشعب الفلسطيني وهي
خطه قائمه منذ 75 عام
والعالم كما حدده القاضه يشاهد والعالم
يشاهد مكتوف الايدي هذه الفضاءات التي
ترتكب من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي بدعم من
الدول الغربيه ونرى امتداد المستوطنات
وسياسه الفصل العنصري في الضفه الغربيه
وحصار غزه ل 17 سنه كل هذه الامور قائمه
كل التقارير الامم المتحده معروفه كل
الهجمات على قطاع غزه انا كنت في قطاع غزه
في الماضي والتقارير متعدده التي رفعت
اقول لك ما هو الشرح الاساسي هو الافلات
من العقاب بالنسبه الى الاسرائيليين وهو
سمح للاسرائيليين ان يقتلوا الفلسطينيين
وان يتوسعوا في سياستهم الاستعماريه من
دون ان يحاسب على عكس مجرمي الحرب الاخرين
في العالم الذين يحاكمون كلا ليس هذا
الحال بالنسبه الى المجرمين الاسرائيليين
هم يحظون بحمايه من قبل الولايات المتحده
ومن السياسيين الجبناء في اوروبا الناس في
الجنوب العالمي الجنوب الدولي يعرفون هذه
الكلمات الاستعمار والفصل العنصري حياه
الفلسطيني يبدو انها لا تساوي حياه الرجل
الابيض وحياه الرجل الاسرائيلي والشخص
الاسرائيلي قمت بعمليه حسابيه حتى الان
31 طفل اسرائيلي قتلوا منذ السابع من
اكتوبر طبعا ما من طفل يجب ان يغتر ولكن
نحن نعرف ان 4000 طفل فلسطيني قتل
وبالتالي الارقام تشير الى انه لكل طفل
اسرائيلي لدينا
166 طفل فلسطيني قتل وهذه النسبه هي تعكس
العنصريه وتعكس الفصل العنصر صور
الابارتايد والسبب هو الافلات من العقاب
لاسرائيل والدعم الامريكي للاستعمار
الاسرائيلي
والسياسيين الجبن على مستوى اوروبا انت
تعرف قطاع غزه بشكل جيد وتعلم وضعه حتى
قبل هذه الحرب في هذه الحرب عندما ليس فقط
تستهدف المستشفيات ولكن تستهدف خزانات
الماء تستهدف المخابز تستهدف حتى الالواح
الطاقه الشمسيه
وبالتالي كيف تتصور
الوضع يمكنني ان اقول التالي انا اعمل في
عملت في مناطق نزاع متعدده وشهدت حروب
متعدده ولقد شاهدت قوى قويه ولكنني لم
اشهد في
حياتي امرا مقززا
وجبانا كهذه الهجمات التي تستهدف حياه
البشر في قطاع غزه هناك مستشفيان
لمعالجه مرضى السرطان الكبار والاطفال
قصفوا المستشفيات لا يمكنني ان اتذكر اي
دوله في كتب التاريخ اي دوله اي جيش اي
حكومه لم تحترم القانون الدولي والقوانين
الدوليه بشكل عام ولكن الاهم قيمه الحياه
البشريه والروح البشريه الفرديه مثل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اذا يمكنني ان اشرح
ذلك من خلال محاوله فهم القياده السياسيه
والقياده العسكريه التي ليس لديها ادنى
احترام لحياه الاخرين فقط يحترمون حياتهم
هم يدوسون على الانسانيه ويدوسون على
القيم الاساسيه عندما تهاجم المستشفى انت
فقط معنى ان تكون انسانا ان تكون بني ادم
وعندما تقطع الماء عن مليوني شخص انت
تتصرف بوحشيه ووفقا لتعريف هذا تعذيب متعم
للناس لان الرحمه هي في صلب وجوهر القيم
البشريه والرحمه تظهرها حتى لاعدائك حتى
لاولئك
الذين لا تحبهم ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي ليس
لديه ذره رحمه
وذره قيم بشريه الرحمه واحترام الروح
البشريه وحمايه الضعفاء ولكن الشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه لا يزال واقفا
لا يلوحون بالرايه البيضاء والاطباء
والممرضون والممرضات يعالجون المرضى
وهؤلاء هم الابطال هم الابطال الذين
يرسمون الطريق لكي نمضي قدما ان نترك
الضعفاء
جاما جانبا ولا نستسلم بل ان نخاطر
بحياتنا هؤلاء هم المثال الذي يحتذى به
وهذا الهج الهائل على الانسانيه الذي
نشاهده للاسبوع الرابع اذا
يجب باشاره لاستهداف المستشفيات في الايام
الاولى استهدف المستشفى المع مدني وقتل
المئات ولم يتحرك العالم بعد مرو شهر هذا
اليوم الناطق باسم الجيش العسكري
الاسرائيلي عاد ليهدد مستشفيات اخرى في
القطاع ولا يك يكاد يمر يوم الا يهدد
باستهداف دا مستشفى اخر في قطاع غزه
وبالتالي ما الذي
[موسيقى]
يريدونه اعتقد انه يتعين عليكم ان تطرحوا
السؤال عليهم انا لست اشعر باي مسؤوليه
شرح لماذا يقصفون المستشفيات ولكن اود ان
اشرح لماذا يجب ان لا يقصف المستشفيات
اطرح السؤال على الجنرال وعلى نتنياهو
وعلى السيد جو بايدن
ما الذي يفكر به عندما يرى المستشفيات
تقصف في العام 2023 هل كان ليقبل ان تقصف
المستشفيات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والتي تؤوي المدنيين الامريكيين هل
الحكومه
الامريكيه تقبل
بقصف المستشفيات الروسيه من قبل
الاوكرانيين على سبيل المثال والاوكرانيين
يقاتلون في مواجهه الروس الذين يحتلون
بلادهم هم لا يقبلون ذلك لماذا لان ذلك
يناقض اسس الانسانيه هناك حاجه لحمايه
الاطفال وحمايه النساء وحمايه النساء
الحوامل والمسنين والمسنات